Feierlaune bei den deutschen Olympia-Sportlern
in Pyeongchang.
Skispringer Andreas Wellinger freute sich
über die am Samstag "erflogene" Goldmedaille.
Schnell habe er gewusst, dass das ein guter
Sprung war,
so Wellinger während der Pressekonferenz zum Sieg.
"Gestern der zweite Durchgang, habe ich direkt
nach dem Absprung gemerkt, ich bin deutlich
höher und weiß, es geht weit, war überzeugt
es geht weit, genauso, dass ich da unten einen
Telemark mach, ohne mit der Wimper zu zucken.
Das ist, glaube ich, auch eine Stärke, die
ich mir die letzten Monate erarbeitet habe,
dass ich eben auch im hohen, weiten Bereich
gute Haltungsnoten kriegen kann."
Stolze 113,5 Meter war der 22jährige Wellinger
geflogen, was ihm 259,3 Punkte einbrachte,
die Norweger Forfang und Johannsson verwies
er auf Silber und Bronze.
Ebenfalls am Samstag hatte bereits Biathletin
Laura Dahlmeier Gold geholt.
Sie gewann den Sprint über 7,5 Kilometer
mit einem Vorsprung von 24,2 Sekunden.
Gemeinsam mit Wellinger ließ sich die 24Jährige
am Samstag
im Deutschen Haus in Pyeongchang feiern.